on a Brazilian Summer's morning the
nation's final day with its icon and
inspiration
for hours they queued through the night
in Santos
for one last moment shared with the
footballer who meant so much more than
football to them
who brought so much joy
pausing at the open casket
to treasure the Glimpse at greatness
on the page where the legend of Pele was
born
where the first goals were scored as a
15 year old
for the club where he spent so much of
his career by government decree
and then the final mourners
was Lula de Silva
flying in two days after being sworn in
as Brazil's president
tender moments were shared with pele's
family
hugging his son
and Widow
before remembering the Majesty of
watching Pele in his prime
the world is indebted to Pele because he
had a hard upbringing he was a black
disenfranchised child and that never
stopped him from becoming such a
dignified person
all of that never hindered him from
becoming Pele despite all the Prejudice
that surrounded him
he was the best whilst being the most
humble
the lying in state befitted the statist
attained through 82 years
24-hour wake ending with his coffin
carried off the field by members of the
military
and leaving the Villa belmiro Stadium
66 years after entering
[Applause]
celebrated through the streets
for the final Journey
and a very public farewell
[Applause]
highest honor brazila Ford Sport Stars
being transported atop a fire engine
just as the team was after the 1970
World Cup through the streets of Brazil
when Pele became the first and still
only winner of three World Cups
[Applause]
images of Pele as the ultimate winner
remained seared on the public
consciousness
and whatever present on the procession
through Santos
which inched through the streets
[Applause]
crowds flooding and slowing the progress
at times
a people not ready to be separated from
their hero
at Canal six masses gathered
outside the home where pele's mother
Celeste orientas still lives
the hundred-year-old was not seen on the
balcony
but there was a way from pele's Sister
Lucia
in appreciation at the love of the
nation
and why being in this port city put on
the map by him was of such significance
on a day so important to them
[Applause]
Pele represents the world to us he paved
the way for five World Cup trophies
putting Brazil on the world stage
palette was the brightest star shining
worldwide being Santos to stardom in
Brazil circus
they send off through the streets lasted
four hours
before reaching his final resting place
on the ninth floor of the world's
tallest Cemetery
and a burial out of public View
in the shadow of the Santos football
stadium
it was the family's chance to mourn in
private the footballer known far beyond
football
a national treasure in Brazil whose
elegance and Grace on the pitch and
scoring prowess captivated the world
and will forever be a footballing
immortal
eternally
King Pele
Rob Harris
Sky News